"We’ll all fly away together…
one last time."
The completion of James Gunn’s Guardians trilogy has some
truly heartbreaking moments. But one death
was seriously not who we were expecting.
Keep watching to find out who that was.
We've known for a long while that the Grim Reaper
has been sharpening its scythe ahead of "Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3." Historically, James Gunn
has killed characters if the reason is good,
and has done so in both previous "Guardians"
movies — the original Groot in the first one
and Yondu in "Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 2." What's more, Gunn dropped
the huge "Vol. 3" bombshell about another
impending character death way back in 2020,
so fans have had plenty of time to think about the
"Guardians" characters who are most likely to die.
Well, Gunn certainly wasn't lying. "Guardians
of the Galaxy Vol. 3" features plenty of death,
from the almost casual end of Sovereign
leader Ayesha to the latest civilization
the High Evolutionary destroys. However, fans
who have been bracing themselves for the death
of a central Guardian character can walk away
from the movie relieved (or disappointed,
depending on your outlook). Despite
multiple extremely close calls,
the heroes all survive the movie and even get
a happy ending to their various character arcs.
That doesn't mean the movie doesn't
feature a particularly grueling death,
though — it's just that instead of killing off
a familiar name, "Vol. 3" opts to establish a
new likable character for this purpose. In what
just might be the most emotional moment in a movie
that's chock full of them, the High Evolutionary
guns Lylla down at the beginning of Rocket's
escape plan. It's a pivotal moment in both the
movie and Rocket's life, and though we've only
known Lylla for a few scenes, her death and its
impact on Rocket is nothing short of devastating.
It can be difficult to market a movie in
a way that attracts potential viewers,
yet doesn't give away too much of the
plot and the big beats. Because of this,
promotional material has to straddle
a fine line, and the end result isn't
always successful — in fact, there are many
trailers that gave away too much of the movie.
"Guardians of the Galaxy Vol. 3," on the other
hand, takes a different approach. While the movie
itself enjoys baiting the viewer with numerous
close calls when it comes to character deaths,
the trailers deceive the viewer in the opposite
way when it comes to Lylla. Marvel fans might go
into the movie with the knowledge that Lylla
and Rocket have quite a happy storyline in
the comics — definitely happier than what they
get in the movie. As such, when the promotional
materials see the adorable otter embracing Rocket
or laughing on the floor, it's all too easy to
take these fleeting moments of happiness as a
sign of a happy reunion for current-day Rocket.
In reality, however, the movie takes a stark turn
for the worse at the moment that happy hug from
the trailers happens. Barely a second after this
familiar moment, the High Evolutionary ruthlessly
shoots Lylla in the back and proceeds to mock
Rocket. As if things weren't already bad enough,
Floor and Teefs perish in the chaos that ensues
from the shooting and Rocket's attack on the
High Evolutionary, leaving the enhanced
raccoon well and truly alone in the world.
Sure, Lylla is a relatively minor character in
the grand scheme of the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
However, her influence on Rocket's life,
the shocking circumstances of her death,
and the immediate, face-ripping
devastation Rocket unleashes in
retaliation add up to one of the most
impactful death scenes in the franchise.